[Music]
and fight for justice news submitted by
finals are coming yes right study why
we're not getting views right now you
guys got a stop study team serving a
life sentence for killing a man after
being forced into the sex industry is
back in the spotlight spotlight is this
who I think it is is it the girl yeah is
she being charged for [ __ ] even though
she was doing it his self defense and
she was at one of the worst situations
in her life I will tell you the entire
situation you can be let me [ __ ] go
because I heard that what's being passed
around on the Twitter's isn't really
what happened inside of the court case
yeah okay let's talk about it let's hear
it cuz all right let's hear good this
story is about some Toya Brown she's now
29 years old she's been in prison for
over a decade
damn what hurt but her cases now
resurface all over social media mainly
because of posts from Rihanna Kim
Kardashian LeBron James are they friends
with her no I'm not really sure like why
all of a sudden it's been popular but
all these celebrities have been posting
this so this image circulating so it's
her photo with her son her story was
like imagine at the age of 16 being sex
trafficked by a pimp named cuttable
after days of being repeatedly drugged
and raped by different men you were
purchased by a 43 year old child
predator who took you to his home to use
you for sexy when defining enough
courage to fight back and shoot and kill
him you you're arrested as a result
tried and convicted as an adult and
sentence of life in prison this is the
story of santoña Brown she will be
eligible for parole when she is 69 years
old free cinto yeah Wow
yeah and Rihanna she posted this on her
IG and she said did we somehow or she
kept and she captioned it did we somehow
change the definition of hashtag justice
all the way cuz something is horribly
wrong when the system enables these
rapists and the victim is thrown away
for life - each of you responsible for
this child sentence I hope
to God you don't have children because
this could be your daughter being
punished for punishing already hashtag
freeze into a brown hashtag helm anymore
I woulda gave her a trophy if this story
was the story but I know that there's
many other stories yeah there's more to
this if that's the first thing I read I
was like this is [ __ ] up this is not
right but there's more to it I saw
comments from other people like hey
y'all need to just read the court case
because when you understand that that's
not what happened
the details are different what are the
damn details because this is what as we
call juicy hmm yeah and they call you
that - that's my stripper name first I
thought I was like why is Tia or Tamera
in a jumpsuit sister-sister you know
yeah Wow Wow let's go this is Kim's post
she tweeted this if she was a petal fall
hunter I would give her a trophy and a
million dollars and I would let her work
undercover and catch all the pedophiles
and haunt them she is she looks Filipino
she did black and Filipino mmm black a
penal okay so her you know
so her case first received a lot of
attention in 2010 because of a
documentary named me facing life the
Santoya Brown story mmm documentaries be
helping people like making a murder
yeah so her background here she suffered
from fetal alcohol syndrome okay so her
mother drank a lot of alcohol when she
was pregnant you guys don't know what I
mean so that means we gotta get to born
already we got to get the mom and make
her drink rubbing alcohol yep
so symptoms of fetal alcohol syndrome
include delayed development problems in
thinking speech movement and social
skills poor judgment
and difficulty with impulse control so
people so that's how like me
your mom no she was just addicted to
that tea that green tea drinking ho
[Laughter]
don't punish me mama entire grew up in
an abusive home and she ran away from
her adoptive parents house between the
ages of 12 to 14 she assaulted at least
one teacher and was involved in roughly
20 assaults on other children what would
it what's the definition of assault
hitting a kiddin me a lot that's
physical okay thank you for moving and
then I saw at 14 she was placed on a
heavy-duty cocktail of drugs for
depression and anxiety and she was
entered into alcohol and drug treatments
that's all sad in psychological
evaluations at that time doctors noted
that she behaved irrationally suffering
from wild mood swings here's a quote
from one of the doctors she had little
sense of self-worth and she expected
others to fail or betray her yet she
acted in ways that made those
expectations reality she was nearly
incapable of trusting anyone yet she
badly desired approval going into this
whole thing mess that she got into she
met a 24-year old named cutthroat who
raped an abuser and forced her into
prostitution
she claims this is a quote from her she
said quote he would explain to me that
some people were born [ __ ] and that I
was one and I was a [ __ ] and nobody
would want me but him and the best thing
I could do was just learn to be a good
[ __ ] in 2004 at the age of 16 she says
that she was solicited for sex by a 43
year old named Johnny Mitchell Allen who
was a real estate guy and so he drove
her back into her back to his house she
says that she resisted his advances and
that he reached under the bed for what
she assumed was a gun because he had
showed her his gun collection and said
that he was a sharpshooter in the army
and so when he was reaching when she
she's claiming that she he was reaching
under the bed for something if she got
scared that he was gonna be shooting her
so she got a gun out of her
own purse that cutthroat gamer and shot
him in the head and so it is a
conflicting testimony because at the
time of her arrest she originally stated
that she shot him when he was asleep but
then she ended up changing her story but
the forensic evidence did not support
her self-defense claim because when they
found him his hands are like under his
body and like he was in a position of
him asleep so that's like the
conflicting things did they have sex do
they know
so there's one that said that she
refused but then there's other report
saying that she did end up having sex
and shot him afterwards so I'm not too
sure like to rob him
yeah so then the court the prosecutors
are saying that she was not motivated by
self-defense but that her intent was to
rob him because she ended up taking his
wallet his guns and his car before
fleeing so that's what happened she was
tried as an adult and convicted of first
degree felony murder and aggravated
robbery and so her possibility for
parole is at the age of 69 because of
the laws that they have in Tennessee
yeah and so right now the prosecutor is
not happy about the current media
attention this is what the prosecutor
said quote there have been a group of
people who have wanted to make miss
brown a victim and a celebrity since
this happened she was not trafficked nor
was she a sex slave it's not fair to the
victim and his family and that the other
side of this case is so seldom heard
it's what the prosecutor saying I'm not
sure exactly why he's claiming that she
wasn't trafficked or maybe he's claiming
that she wanted to live that life or
something no one wants to live that life
no one says I aspire to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] when I grow up I want so much dick
and AIDS I'm gonna be the best [ __ ]
ho in the world no one wants that [ __ ]
and then place a few ages 16 like
they're driven into that yeah someone
[ __ ] manipulates them someone makes
them feel that they don't have any you
know self-worth or anything and then
they manipulate them they don't have a
[ __ ] father fear so then this pimp
comes around I protect you [ __ ] you
wanna Mack bucket [ __ ] that's what
happens and in some guy with three first
names comes up and wants to [ __ ]
billy-bob Joe [ __ ] Johnny Mitchell
person Johnny Mitchell Allen first of
all you don't trust anybody with three
first names that sounds like three
[ __ ] people and why does he have
multiple personality disorder I don't
know okay Joe Joe I'm a mystery man but
let's go back to this story even if he
was just a regular army guy that wanted
some pool say she was underage right
what I saw other report saying too that
she admitted to lying about her age when
he picked her up it's just a big ol mess
but the fina doesn't help her case is if
she left with his guns in his car and
it's muddy yeah that's that's just
robbery regardless of what happened if
you know even if she got raped or
whatever there is aspect of murder and
robbery to it but I don't know all the
other details I gave if he did
repeatedly rape her and do all that
stuff than the eye could see the self
defense but even if in self-defense if
you still leave with all those items it
doesn't help her case at all wait wait
was he in like quote unquote possession
of her like he owned her is that what
she's he the the guy that was murdered
that's what you elicited okay pic so cuz
he also I'm guessing like the other
thing that's very odd is that this
person had to be have been comfortable
with her and her whatever hooker job
though she was doing the point that he
was coming off to sleep around her so he
was relaxed he was shot and why would he
show her his gun collection exactly so
he wasn't in fear of his life if he was
shot to sleep that means he was
comfortable to sleep there to be shot
that's like that's why [ __ ] a peep
dead [ __ ] I don't know if you did or
not but even that's like you don't say
you don't just sleep around the hooker
yeah yeah y'all sleep with the stranger
in her house yep I'd be like where's my
wallet
mm-hmm I'd be sleeping with my [ __ ]
purse bag like this thanks for the
[ __ ] but I got to go to sleep now
I'm lock-in my room I I feel pretty bad
for her though because even though what
she did was like illegal she murdered a
man or whatever but think about how
[ __ ] up her life was all throughout
her life
she's getting repeatedly raped and all
that and then you add you asked this
portion to act morally and stand up like
what the [ __ ] just set up to fail
Society failed on this person a lot of
people that want to see her free that's
the argument here to it so yeah her
mom's [ __ ] her up she was born into
[ __ ] failure and you expect a moral
person I mean yes she did something
wrong but then and it doesn't make what
she did any better but it's like it's
almost like da I think for her she has
to just pay the consequences of her
actions but til 69 is really really
extreme there are people who do way
worse than that I get way that that's
the weird [ __ ] there's people that get
away with [ __ ] worse yeah yeah so
because of some toy escape they actually
changed some laws to help like teens
that have been convicted yeah because
right now apparently with the lies like
if you get convicted or something like
this and you're not eligible for parole
until 50 51 or 53 years until after so
then that's the fucked-up part it's like
an entire life is your entire life is
gone just because of a mistake when you
were a teen so they're trying to change
it to be more fair like more
proportionate to the age and the context
yeah have you guys seen that meme they
put this one next to the Stanford yeah
there's a Brock Turner oh yeah that bull
raped a girl right and then he got away
with it I thought that's no dog posted I
think the one cuz cuz his family knew
the judge or something like that right
cuz they were rich yeah that's some
crazy [ __ ] man there's a guy that she
killed yeah and so now that she's been
in prison she she's been studying she
did complete an associate's degree so
she's now working for towards her
bachelor's is that jail College yeah
good for her yeah I think she did her
time and if she's becoming reformed then
you know you know it it sucks when you
hear stories where people were not given
the chance to even live a normal life
and it's like when they do something
like murder or whatever it's like how
dare you they're judged hella hard what
a [ __ ] do you expect if you were if you
were [ __ ] from birth you saw people
stealing
robbing killing shooting [ __ ] raping
you you were used as a [ __ ] toy you were
[ __ ] drugged up at the age of seven
it's like what the [ __ ] do you expect
even McDonald's won't hire ass it's like
and then you're like oh you shouldn't be
killed people it's like Society failed
honor man doesn't make what she does
okay but that's the weird-ass [ __ ] I
don't know to me I just want to sprinkle
love dust on everybody love dust let
them change it yeah a little bit of
cracking weed thinking of a [ __ ] EDM
party okay where everyone's having fun
[Music]